yeah welcome to this live broadcast I
hope in life it's all his kind of tricky
if you have this delay of a couple of
seconds okay yeah I hope you guys enjoy
yourself going to start right away with
a couple of blitz games yeah that's been
some nice games also today in Tata Steel
but you will have coverage here on the
ISS see with the game of the day
then I well suppose something on my
channel later okay well let's go for
some games yeah it seems that I'm really
online thanks for the feedback in the
chat I'm watching the chat window
closely so let's get going
some five-minute action oops
that was quick Brady harder probably
tougher to play than Brady soft alright
so let's see my to f3 yeah going for
some g6 base stuff Kings inion hmm yeah
I'd like to play with d5 this Greenfeld
type of thing never lie to fianchetto
Kings Indian that much okay
he's playing with Knight to c3 maybe I
can get beef Ivan just trying to keep
the pawn I'm that kind of materialistic
person I want this pawn Knight if I
always have 94 so maybe I can put in
this this night on on V form okay
yeah night before trying to go to D 3
hmm it's possible I can also put this
out maybe I should the bishop is not
doing that much
yeah let's jump in d3 is a nice square
so this pawn on c4 might do something
good for me okay so 93 is not leading to
that much though we can play b3 mm I can
go a 6 b5 let's prepare u5 again under
2400 rating yep ups and downs but if you
play during the project like my my book
my the final stages of my book it's
really difficult you are really not
focused enough at times I really found
that out so night 23 or not now let's
jump in if he goes b3 yeah I have
interesting moves I have a queen a5 I
have a 5 actually yeah I'm gonna be 5
okay e5i rd5 hmm okay let's see yeah it
will take with the knight on d5 yes I
didn't really think about that that
detail so Queen f5 maybe after all well
maybe if I wasn't that successful job
blitz matches against some some people
yeah I mean I'm happy to exception and
just really not so much into challenging
some people myself
Bishop to d2 hmm
yeah maybe you will just try to remove
this annoyed can I do this
this looks really enterprising try to
activate stuff I'm not sure about it it
looks a bit thinking here maybe I can
take C form
yeah for normal international master
like I am to play a blitz match against
the world champion is probably not a
really interesting preposition I would
just lose every game maybe the odd draw
when he falls asleep or something
so okay that's not good
yeah I really miss played this terribly
he can also take with the night now 497
ah what a bad game
yeah well this this is not that terrible
actually I think I'm not in good shape
but still it seems that I'm not lost at
least
Jeff white is still better deep on being
really really annoying
Queen d4 and the Budapest is really just
bad I think especially against the
Budapest White has a ton of good lines
so there's really not any nests that's
not really necessary to play some
substandard stuff okay
what am i doing in this position a7 is
under huge pressure and there's d6
possibly coming Wow hmm can take a form
it's probably bad in any case very
difficult to to say what some best I
haven't stopped posting those streams on
YouTube it's just that last week was a
different kind of stream and this was
something that was exclusive for ICC and
shouldn't be posted on my channel so I
might get in the bishop trade which
would be helping
I am but how do I change now with I
think with that night probably I'm not a
huge fan of the reverse benoni positions
out of the Reggie opening mostly you're
giving up your first move with right but
if you like the structure you can play
all kinds of things so I want to get
this night on a 600 pile some somewhere
okay he wants to get a knight to c6 it
seems do mind that very much the C pawn
I will pick up quickly it's still a very
tough position I don't have any
advantage or anything of the like he's
doing a really good job
f3i probably wants to get in Bishop f1
I'm not sure how dangerous that is
yeah I am group tries to invade that's
really passive I know maybe I can trade
some stuff 38 seconds that's not good
Knight comes to c6 yeah that looks
strange but Wow but that is not only
looking strange it is strange yeah I
have to cover b6 not much else there is
to do okay that's really really terrible
this position cannot even activate the
rook somehow
now he's starting to think it's quite
quite amazing oh that's nice I'd love to
get in the Rope trade his route was much
stronger than mine so anyway to get back
to him
and now we're taking a four to one I'm
getting an away let's do this
this is now a pretty good end game just
have to be the nerd he's tied to the e4
pawn
whoo I could have taken maybe yeah well
at the end I did it in the endgame but
hey someone is asking me I should make a
video about time management in blitz
are you joking my time management is so
terrible not a good idea let's let's
start another game here's a question
about my chess club who that got two
young players a couple of years ago from
a neighboring City how they are
progressing either progressing or right
they play in our team we played
yesterday in a crucial match in the
German league doing a right they scored
one win one draw very nice so this is
the the English defense to the English
opening one b6 trying to do something
with f5 being active okay I have to take
yeah playing again stretchy probably a
fan of the inventor of the reti opening
Knight to f5 is my idea let's do that
yeah that's that's a fine line that he
played it's a good choice against my my
b6 setup white will always be a little
bit better here he's got pressure on
those pawns so it's not easy for me to
play J probably covered d7
yeah I'm probably not playing against
Richard Red Team I am the the real which
had read him was dead for probably ages
but you never know you never know cause
I once played a game against maroc see
the guy who has the more oxy bind named
after him and he played it via mediums a
person who said he could communicate
them with more oxy in the back in the
afterlife let's say this is a good and
it was an interesting game it was a
French defense quite funny and the ghost
of maroc C played pretty well yeah white
is better yeah what can I do
the knight the rook on g4 is kind of
funny probably he he wants to do
something here with them Bishop takes h6
I hope it's not not working ever trying
to go with the e5 I want to block the
position as much as possible so that my
knight is a useful piece he's opening it
up why is he playing this so well that's
not good not good for my chances of
success what I'm trying to say yeah I
had to take and somehow my look is on
this bishop but I really don't know I
cannot place it anywhere anywhere
serious may be here for Knight h4
I'm not sure who's going to credit for
qualify for the next candidates the
caution Irma Roxie game of the draw I
think if it really was my rock ski it's
that's funny right um for the candidates
I don't know probably
I mean Tijuana will probably qualify by
rating I believe or maybe Aronian I
don't know I'm not totally sure the next
candidates tournament is in 2015 in 2016
I'm sorry so some things like average
rating Wow now that's not going to work
come on if I was hanging here 93-yard
says something better
come on that wins one win is enough so I
was just picking up picking up this
exchange wait
yeah okay that's totally fine so this
chick yeah let's just play for them play
for the extra exchange that I have how
do I convert it look - eh probably yeah
I definitely also would look forward to
a match Townsend against Cara wanna the
the other person I would really like to
see in a World Championship matches as
curry shocked by the way I'm totally
sure that this would be an interesting
match I probably said it said it at one
point in another stream that I like to
see Grisha get a match and I would like
to win this game by the way an extra
exchange is nice but he puts up some
some resistance here this guy okay then
Roop here on age six hmm I can maybe get
in gonna get in c5 and King f6 but then
he has got the rook coming over and I
need some activity him Knight f3 b5 is a
bad opening night at three Knight f6 g3
p5 is fine I mean really fine so how do
I win this now check while c5 it's not
like he has many squares for this Bishop
this Bishop does not have many squares
if I go rook F 3 is Bishop
h1
okay I just grabbed the queenside it
should be totally enough you in chess is
an excellent magazine really it's the
only magazine that I really considered
to be essential to be honest there are
others but at least in Germany okay I
cannot really say anything about like
American chess magazines are really my
knowledge there's very very limited but
or non-existent let's say but if you are
in Germany you only need new in chess
actually don't need any other magazine
so this is winning i hope winning this
this bishop yeah or this one how do I do
that now come on I'm gonna have to stop
the porn right I shouldn't shouldn't
just let it promote I'm probably not
playing this in the best possible way
from a technical point of view but it
will be sufficient that's a question
what what do I think what cars is rating
will peak at you want a funny answer to
that probably as high as he wants it to
be within reason I mean I'll still think
he has some some some yeah there's some
some some potential still and depends on
his work ethic ethics
I think 2900 is very very very very
impossible oh no that would blunder I
shouldn't do that
if I just returned he will he will walk
in with this King which is not a great
idea I should just pick up stuff what's
easiest probably this year forcing him
to c3 yeah or this one which allows d5
or octave for me
yeah come on 30 seconds I will manage
this right and here I can already go to
King opponent games if I want but it's
not really necessary
you can of course do that but just with
the with the rook on the board it's very
easy
okay resigned um
let's do a new game there was a what
questions are there yeah that's a
question if I have any further goes with
my rating not really I just tried to
play better and see what happens
it's a generally good policy try to play
well and the rest comes so we have mrs.
sky I really want to check that don't
know this guy
Jonas investor Burke okay yeah I don't
play much chess cube tournaments because
um that's the level of competition is
you know and sometimes they are just
cancelled okay this is curious this guy
is playing playing my line my opening
repertoire line in the that I'm going to
publish in my upcoming book the Zurich
variation of the classical that's cute
okay let's see how he handles this
position will be interesting yeah widens
or enjoys a space advantage and some
some hope connected to the bishops b6 is
somewhat unusual in this position to be
it's a bit of a euphemism it's it's
really not a good move normally to
weaken yourself but maybe it was varied
that I will actually take the a five
point think of it he might we have I
could have done that maybe but wow this
is just a good good positional way to
play how I'm doing it with before yeah
this night is not really well placed
here this is this kind of combination of
moves you normally don't want to play
Knight a6 in the structure
you want the night out on d7 and maybe
Bishop to g4 okay it's probably I'm
probably not the best person to play
this line against I have probably spent
dozens of hours on it which does not
mean that I'm necessarily going to win
this game easily but I definitely have
some some some ideas about the position
okay so how am I going to do this now
mmm c5 is a move I can also try to
regroup the Knight to c3 there are many
interesting ways to play this he has
maybe ninety eight and possibly f5 I can
place the bishop against this one idea
and yeah there you normally just go g3
and try to ignore them okay it's
interesting
hey I see but I can take a four now it's
probably aiming for this counter-attack
with f5 so should I play I should take a
four or not an interesting question that
kind of litmus places the Queen quite
clearly I'm not sure
okay I will take it it's kind of tricky
maybe I shouldn't have taken it and try
to focus on limiting the counter play
but I don't think this is so dangerous
maybe I'm wrong okay
one idea that I have is f4 which is a
very brutal move I don't know let's do
that
it's just a game of blitz chess try to
open up the long diagonal yeah my king
is definitely not very safe yeah it
looks kind of exposed but whenever he
moves the e pawn now Queen d4 will be
excellent that's there's a question will
i autographed books probably but there
is no clear solution yet for that there
might be something that that can be done
but it's not it's not yet the time 24 or
takes on e5 mm-hmm
I really want to have it published first
you know yeah I'm sometimes worried that
people actually watch my stuff and use
it for preparation against me but not
very much I really care more about the
content that I produce then some single
game that might happen it's it's really
not that focused on my my own play
anymore
I like to enjoy to play some good games
and it's it's all fine but I really
don't worry so much that people use my
internet videos for preparation okay so
we plan to play Queen f6 I can take it
simply and now we'll take f5 then take
f4 it's not that brilliant maybe but
have rupees seven so maybe this is the
way to go going for a quick look 287
yeah I can take F for night H 5 rupees
seven rook F seven it's definitely
holding on him John
I wonder probably there's not much point
in taking on therefore anyway so trying
to go to the seventh rank Wow he allows
me to take them no I will I will take c7
don't think that this is a bad
transformation for me maybe I'm under
estimating the threats to my king that's
definitely possible okay that's trade
and trying to catch the b6 bond I just
got b5 maybe maybe b5 okay it's not
doing that right Knight here for Knight
g5 he would probably play aged six
no he won't
hmm it's not worried about that okay I
don't have that much time so I have to
be quick I'm going to give up this pawn
for rookie seven trying to attack him
take him quickly
maybe age six hmm yep
still rookies seven maybe yeah that's
probably not more than an equal position
I guess it's hard to do something else
though I can do this maybe nice good
rookie ed huh okay let's do it
yes take the knight now I guess
everything else would be quite
surprising
yeah so I will just just grab everything
here I guess
look III maybe I don't know I'm this
this is quite Josh maybe the time is the
deciding factor probably we will trade
trade everything here can take b6 I can
also try to keep the a3 porn but not
sure that this leads to anything that's
really very dry
yeah it's completely equal material and
be porn against Jeep on he's just
trading everything down that's that's
overdraw yep okay draw a greet that was
that was pretty good probably at some
point but he escaped with it wrong yeah
some more over the board games yeah I
will do some of my over the board games
probably from this tournament that I'm
going to play in my York I also played a
funny young played a funny game
yesterday in the league not sure when I
will do that video from yesterday's game
was a crazy game early yeah this
question do I think that card is
attention playing offbeat or bad opening
so that his future opponent cannot
prepare against him I'm not sure I think
it's actually a good thing that he's
experimenting a little bit it's not a
very exciting idea to have the Berlin
opening in the way played all the time
just some variety is good I like it that
he's playing the Dutch defends and g6
and stuff like that it didn't work today
and I feel that he Bluffs probably
pretty badly against white a shake I
didn't see the game clearly I had other
things to do all day but well it's the
better to see him experimenting a little
bit and then some dull stuff so it's a
it will lead to some defeats but it will
also lead to interesting games so an
interesting opening here the Queens
gambit declined somewhat rare line that
my opponent is playing here aha he wants
to grap on b2
it feels very very lame to cover the
porn so I don't do that 95
well okay maybe I can
my idea is after ete takes which I
expect you to go here and then play Eve
for next trying to open up the position
as quickly as possible yeah a sound
quoting Petrosian that the Dutch defense
should be prevented if your opponent
intends to do it that's probably true
well but where the Dutch defense is not
that terrible really but it's of course
not as solid as great as some other
openings still I think it's good that
the world champion is doing some some
some experimenting yeah but some it
feels like he deserves to you have some
creative leave a yeah
probably will lead to some some
interesting stuff so this is an
interesting position it doesn't look
like that but this is a very classical
type of position this is the pawn
structure typically known as the RAM
structure the RAM like in the animal it
is some looking like to ram here on d4
d5 so it's a typical structure that
normally is a little bit more
comfortable here for the white side
simply because I have the better minor
piece for the structure however this is
an exceptionally solid position for
black and he has got the C file this is
not really that great for me Queen to c2
probably yeah there's not much going on
I admit that I played this really and
this was a bit lame how I played this
but maybe he's under estimating things
and I'm trying to trade rooks here if he
trades rooks I will continue
to play this forever and I will have
slide chances in this end game he should
play Roxy one that's much easier while
trading it's not terrible of course but
I will definitely continue then and
let's see here what am i doing now I
want to improve the night the night
should come to III ideally how do I get
them three three night age 492 is kind
of thing or he had to eat too that's
actually not bad
92 to c3 that's that's also good one
tonight
where'd looks at the d5 pawn c3 or yeah
Knight c3 probably and now I will
activate the King the the main thing was
to to get the rook out of it me I want
to want it to push the rook back now I
can use the King get it to e3 maybe yep
that's okay f5 now looks active but I'd
like to get a pawn to f4 him I can
actually start with that it's not bad
gaining some space
maybe irritating him a little bit so
group to f2 well now the rock might be
useful on the F file takes takes rook f6
yeah how is he playing this now it's a
little bit annoying this idea mm-hmm
so he elects to play g4 well now I have
the better pawn structure and he has a
weakness on h5 how do I continue here I
would like to improve my coordination
can the rook enter somehow okay he's
still okay he's still okay
I think I probably have to try to trade
rooks like rook see one night a - I just
have to get rid of the rooks otherwise
and I never get get anywhere Knight a -
right let's see who he allows me to
trade so b3 is the move so that he
trades on c1 yeah this is now this is
now something that I can continue to
press for ever and ever and ever and he
now allowed another pawn on a light
square now that that's another helpful
move the question is still can I win it
it's a very nice position but it's not
easy to win Knight to III would be cute
hmm how do I get down
Knight to h4 then f5 king f4 Knight to
b3 it's not easy to get in on one minute
whoops that's not good
and I just allowed this move mm-hmm not
good Wow I screw this up
ah I forgot about this Bishop move no
that's terrible
that's terrible what
he's not taking it that's it's quite
weird no no I can't play for a win again
maybe he wants to try to win on time but
that is risky business in no way I just
have 20 something seconds but still
can you go H form mmm okay when I do
this yeah my time management costs me
here he can take on G for now which she
doesn't do okay he keeps I keep giving
him chances which she summer doesn't
take
that will be tough with the clock but I
probably move managed somehow I was a
bit silent I'm sorry for that but it was
really nerve-racking that's one of those
classic finishes we okay wow that was
that was tough
who was that guy he really is you really
didn't take his chances whoo so next one
I want 2500 and again by the way
breaking this nice little barrier let's
let's go for that Chamberlain
Wow what a question do I make more money
with chess than in Melwood job this is
probably something that can be answered
for absolutely every person who was
doing chest no I don't I don't have no
money now but it's still a good thing to
do so the Kings Indian to play I wanted
to try the Petrosian the Petrosian
system this is Grandmaster Gavriel off I
think I think Alexei Gavriel off yeah
this is an icy old timer he's played on
the isis eve well when i started in 1998
this is when i played on the ice I see
for the first time 1998 17 years ago
okay very
complicated very complicated line in the
Kings Indian I haven't cancelled yet and
I'm not sure that I will cancel quickly
and try to gain some saw him some space
on the queenside first hmm my to see
soon he maybe wants to play with b5 at
some point but now I can
I think Castle I mean I could have done
it before but I am I wanted to make some
headway on the Kings side first a on the
Queen side first I'm sorry I'm so kind
of rattled a bit from the head from the
game before yeah
what am i doing maybe a form well okay
that's the most normal move ever in the
Kings Indian but I wasn't sure if he
really wanted to play it immediately I'm
going to try to open up the position now
in the center B takes and the b5 cares'
old handler nice to see her just caught
Magnus and have played him under the
under this handle with his handle but
the games are not stored in ICC's
database ICC has a database storage of
games but they only store the games of
title players forever and then I didn't
even have the freedom master registered
and he also was untitled I played him
when he was like 11 years old or
something this is actually funny what is
this guy doing he's totally getting
himself annihilated in the center this
looks terrible but I still have every I
mean I know I know how I play I can
definitely screw this up but it's a
fantastic position for wide
I've got huge position on the queenside
on the center very nice
so we took them and I just recaptured
keeping things simple
well the rook hangs look f7 maybe Bishop
ever Bishop c4 simply asking him if he
really wants to go to f6 it looks
terrible I'm just doing that asking the
rook and oh I really overlooked that one
that's also bad I really shouldn't have
overlooked that oh wow that's not good
probably Queen b3 yeah that's the only
move that makes any remote sense if he
plays Queen d2 I take on e6 how this
works
there should be six ultimately know I
have rook c1 yeah I can take only six
can take him
Queen c3 Roxy one Queen moves and then I
take the rook on f7 so it should be good
for me
rook f6 is what he can play and I didn't
see that one but I can go back to b3
that's a shaky position I have many
unprotected pieces just what I tell my
students say don't let your pieces out
there unprotected to lose pieces drop
off but well it happens in blitz I never
played against a Carney knowledge really
never well maybe in some random blitz
game and on SEC but not really that I'm
knew that I was playing him
yeah Quincy freem I will take I will
play rook c1 and the only then take the
rook on gonna have six okay hmm I keep
overlooking things here that's really
not good at all okay should be for us
good 95 he will take c5 I mean this move
isn't so clear yeah but still still I
should have seen that rooks III if I go
if I go look c1
he's got Quincy 100 K he's got Quincy 1
so I have to do that yeah rook c8 is
something he's got really really poor
pieces the piece coordination that he
has is not good but I don't know how
terrible it really is see any takes
takes Queen back maybe I need this rook
then it does rook as well I guess and
it's not so clear what his next move is
really yeah I completely completely I
overlooked everything in this game but
it's still it's still like not clear
on c8 or look on the seventh can also
just take on f5 hey let's start with
that he has to recapture anyway rook c8
it's not not that great and this cut has
got the Queen coming yeah I'm not sure
about it it's it struck him so rook t8
I'm going to get checkmated yeah so not
a good idea
maybe h3n2 to make sure that I'm not
made over there and he will play Queen
b3 probably to cover g8 and then I
wanted to take b7 okay
yeah a form that's good
activating this bishop mmm taking a
seven is probably not a great idea
I wonder ever if I get them get the pawn
I tried to get the a seven pawn no I did
not yet say anything about this thing
that I have for my channel reviewing
viewer games I will get to that but I
will probably do it only when I have
played my tournament this is GM
tournament
let's send no I'd have to take I have to
check okay
yeah I think the the the b-pawn now will
prove decisive I hope and I hope I'm not
meeting myself or anything it could
happen mmm I probably had something
better but hehe lost some time yeah he
lost some time that was a tricky
position I probably didn't play that too
well but it was always somewhat tricky
the b-pawn yeah havin an out an offer
that you can send me games and I will do
a video review on my youtube channel so
but I have somewhat thinks of on my
plate that I would probably only do it
much much later probably in February in
motto here we go that's an Argentinian
Argentinian I am okay I will do this
funky a5 line for the final game this is
funny f5 the big counter-attack the
adelaide county gambit funny counter
against the queen's
Kings gambit if someone is rated is
someone at 13 years old and rated 2300
what are the chances of becoming world
champion zero just zero it's it's like
that I sometimes play the French but not
often I have played it a lot some years
ago but not so much in recent years my
results weren't that great
what I what is he doing he's just giving
me this piece that's nice
huh okay I'm kind of baffled hmm okay so
what he's saying is that he has got
Queen to h5 yes Wow
cool
that's an amazing move okay it's hard to
not take it really but that's it's
really really cool it's really difficult
now to move this piece it's really
difficult to do
we should have five takes on f6 Wow
let's it's totally crazy I cannot
retreat the noid I probably have to
return this piece somehow like this but
now very very hard to play this he will
get to get his piece back here for sure
but maybe I can play like that I should
have played that much quicker of course
Queen d2 now otherwise I take on deform
Queen d2 and then I can move the knight
I wonder only if I have some other move
takes takes I can't just move the knight
it's not like that's impossible
yeah that's the King's gambit for you
get utterly crazy stuff early on
yeah someone understands what's going on
what's going on that would be helpful to
to know and what you think oh wow
it should be winning somehow for black
but it's it's so crazy you can easily
make some some stupid mistake yeah and
now if I move this night I also have
Bishop before actually just putting this
out in the open but moving the knight is
not bad probably this is an easy
solution I mean I'm a piece up and the
only move of any meaning is g5 and then
I play Bishop c5 or a6 probably a six is
easier I don't know
hmmm this this move I did not expect so
well I could just play Bishop yeah not a
good idea okay just just play it first
move first thing later
yeah yeah this was kinda clear so that
dropped that back
now let's let's get rid of this body pin
so that I'm actually keeping this piece
Bishop g5 is the red if you move the
rook then d4 Falls yeah this is this is
just a winning position for black but
it's nothing that is so easily done oh
no a king is relatively safe yeah if I'm
not managing that it's kind of I really
should I think this Bishop on g6 is
really really great yeah
covering f7 just great and well he has
to play something like that yep
well this this is really just a piece
just an extra piece for black one minute
11 yeah I still can't do that
and I'm threatening 95 and Quincy form
Knight b6 this system moves I don't see
it I really don't see it Queen takes
Queen e8 Queen B 1886
now that's burning for black unless I'm
overlooking something
Knight is 7 though Wow Wow light is 7 I
can go quick invader I'm lucky here that
97 are really overlooked but King b8 is
possible
so if I take now now it's used Oh see I
can just take them right yeah let's just
take the night yeah and the bishop
coming here should be the end of it yeah
or the [ __ ] trade or whatever so we
resigned well that's a cool run yeah I
always have those three runs when I'm
doing the streams not always but this is
a fantastic result I got five and a half
out of six just one draw conceded yeah
we above the one-hour mark it was a fun
thing six six games five and a half
points good stuff yeah I hope you
enjoyed this it was a it was a it was a
funny game at the end I hope you liked
it I didn't answer that many questions
today I tried but I wanted to play some
some good games and well I'm not sure
that I managed to play really good games
but it was it was fun at least I hope
you enjoyed it make sure - yeah - tune
in next week important next week there
is no show because I'm on the on a
vacation so not the tournament yet I'm
on a one-week vacation just to relax a
little bit so it's nothing on next week
but make sure to tune in also to them if
you're a member of the ICC to them
coverage for Tata Steel I'll be
broadcasting on Thursday by the way my
first ICC live broadcast of a big GM
tournament event together with Joe
Benjamin I'm looking forward to that
very much trying to explain or irritate
people about chess okay well thanks for
watching this broadcast I'll be back in
two weeks I guess one Thursday if you
watch them the broadcast of Tata Steel
thanks and bye